SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I WROTE TO YOU. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER.
BLAKESPEAR BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY. UH, RAO. BEEN
GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAYERED LIONE
MAGUIRE. MENJIVAR. MEN. NEWMAN.
WHEN NELO OCHO PADILLA. OR, YOU
KNOW ROTH. RUBIO. THE ARTO.
SKINNER. SMALL QUAVERS STERN.
HUMBERG WAHHAB. WEINER. WILL.
MEMBERS OF CORM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS.
BEYOND THE RAIL, PLEASE RISE AND
IN THE GALLERY WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY OUR CHAP
CHAPLAIN SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN,
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU
TO REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE. AND IN THE PRESENCE OF
ONE ANOTHER. AND IN THE WORDS OF
IRISH POET PADRAIG Ó THA WE
GREET GOD. AND WE GREET THE GOD
WHO IS MORE GOD THAN THE GOD WE
GREET. AND AS WE CELEBRATE THE
FEAST OF ST PATRICK THESE DAYS
WE PRAY FOR HIS INTERCESSION. TO
HELP US BE PEOPLE OF HOPE. AS WE
NAVIGATE THE CHALLENGES OF OUR
DAY. MAY WE FIND CONSOLATION IN
THIS TRADITIONAL IRISH PRAYER?
LOOSELY TRANSLATED FROM THE
GAELIC. èC SHIEL. GOD OF ALL
MYSTERY. YOURS IS THE SEED.
YOURS IS THE HARVEST. GATHER US
ONE DAY INTO YOUR GRANARY. G AS
FAST AS THE OCEAN. YOURS ARE THE
WAVES. YOURS ARE THE FISHES.
GATHER US UP INTO YOUR ENTWINING
NETS. FROM BIRTH TO AGE AND FROM
AGE TO DEATH. CREATE LESS IN
YOUR GRACE AND LOVING ARMS. FROM
DEATH TO THE END. NUS AND BUT
NEW LIFE. IN YOUR PRESENCE. MAY
WE RESIDE ETERNALLY. AMEN.
MEMBERS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. SPACE OF
AMERICA. I.
MHM. MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SENATE RULE 55 WILL BE SUSPENDED
TO ALLOW GUESTS ON THE FLOOR FOR
TODAY'S SESSION. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO SENATE
THIRD READING TO TAKE UP SENATE
RESOLUTION 77 ITEM 29 BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE SECRETARY PLEASE READ IN
A RESOLUTION 77 BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE RELATIVE TO IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. MCGUIRE
FOR YOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR
PRESIDENT AND GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS. WE ASK ALL TO RAISE
THEIR CHAIR ALE TODAY FOR S¼ R
77 COMMEMORATE MARCH AS IRISH
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH. YOU
KNOW THIS YEAR IS ESPECIALLY
SIGNIFICANT AS WE CELEBRATE A
CENTURY, A CENTURY OF UNITY AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GREAT
COUNTRY OF IRELAND AND THE
UNITED STATES, THE ROLE OF IRISH
AMERICANS ARE DEEPLY EMBEDDED IN
THE HISTORY AND THE COMMUNITIES
OF CALIFORNIA AS SOME OF
AMERICA'S FIRST. IMMIGRANTS
THEIR HISTORY, THEIR STORIES,
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. THEY ARE A
TESTAMENT TO THE AMERICAN DREAM.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR. LIKE ALL
WHO SEEK A BETTER LIFE IN THE
UNITED STATES. THEIR ROAD TO
THIS NATION WAS NOT EASY. AND AT
A TIME AT A TIME WHEN SOME IN
THIS COUNTRY NOW SEEK TO VILIFY
THOSE WHO ARE FLEEING POVERTY.
POLITICAL PERSECUTION. OR A
BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR KIDS. WE
MUST NEVER FORGET WHAT AMERICA'S
PROMISE IS ALL ABOUT. DIVERSITY
IS OUR STRENGTH. AND THE UNITED
STATES IS PROUDLY A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS. THE IRISH AMERICAN
STORY IS ONE OF RESILIENCE OF
HARD WORK AND SUCCESS, AND THE
GOLDEN STATE'S BOND WITH IRELAND
IS UNRELENTING. IRELAND IS A TOP
TRADE PARTNER WITH THE GOLDEN
STATE WORTH OVER $4 BILLION OVER
100 AND 40. IRISH COMPANIES HAVE
SET UP SHOP HERE IN THE WEST,
PRIMARILY IN CALIFORNIA. SO
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE VIRUS,
THE VIBRANT IRISH AMERICAN
COMMUNITY OF OVER 2 MILLION
STRONG THAT LIVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ASKED TODAY WE
ALL RAISE A LITTLE BIT OF GREEN
GUINNESS IN GRATITUDE OF THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE IRISH
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO THE GOLDEN
STATE HAPPY S'S DAY. MR
PRESIDENT WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN I VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR MIN. I THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. AND I WANT TO THANK
THE PRO TEM FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND AS THE ONLY
KOREAN AMERICAN IN THE
LEGISLATURE, UH, I JUST WANNA
NOTE THAT KOREANS ARE SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO AS THE IRISH OF THE
EAST. AND SO I URGE YOU ALL TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HERE IN
CæA, SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. I WROTE A DEAL. AYE,
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY. HØI ATKINS.
AYE, BECKER. HØI BLAKESPEAR. I,
BRADFORD. BY CABALLERO. I,
CORTEZ. I DALLY. IY DODD.
PERAZZO IY EGM. HIY GLASER. AYE,
GONZALEZ. I GROVE. I HURTADO. I.
JONES. HØI LAIRD. HØI LIMÓN. I
MCGUIRE AYE, MINAR. AYE. MEN.
HØI NEWMAN. AYE. WIN. HØI NILO.
IY. BUT YOU I ARGENTINO. I ROCK.
AYE, RUBIO. I SAY ARE TO
SKINNER. A SMALL CUEVAS. I STERN
I UMBERG W. HØI WIENER. I WILL.
HØI SENATOR MAGUIRE MOVES THE
CALL. NOW WE'RE RETURNING TO
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR.
PRESIDENT MR. PRESIDENT WE ARE
SO HONORED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
TWO REMARKABLE LEADERS WITH US
HERE TODAY WHO HAVE BEEN
INTEGRAL IN CONTINUING THE
CENTURY LONG PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
IRELAND. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WE'RE HONORED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
SENATOR JERRY BUT HERE TODAY HE
IS CHAIR OF THE IRISH SENATE. WE
ALSO HAVE COUNSEL GENERAL
MICHAEL SMITH, IRON IRELAND'S
COUNCIL GENERAL FOR THE ENTIRE
UNION, WESTERN UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND I WANNA SAY THANK
YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR WHO IS
HERE TODAY. THE SENATOR IS A
TRAILBLAZER. HE LED THE CHARGE
TO APPROVE MARRIAGE EQUALITY IN
IRELAND IS ONE OF THE FIRST OUT
MEMBERS OF THE L GB Tð Q
COMMUNITY EVER TO BE ELECTED TO
IRELAND'S HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES. WE GIVE A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE, PLEASE AND SAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HE ALSO
GAVE A HELL OF A SPEECH. UH,
WITH JOE BIDEN WHEN HE WAS OVER
THERE, SO YOU SHOULD GOOGLE THAT
BUT LIKE CALIFORNIA, A MARRIAGE
EQUALITIES NOW LAW OF THE LAND,
THANKS TO THE SENATORS. HARD
WORK IN IRELAND, AND WE ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE COUNSEL
GENERAL SMITH. HE WORKS DAY IN
AND DAY OUT TO BUILD AND
STRENGTHEN THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND THE GREAT
COUNTRY OF IRELAND MEMBERS. IF
WE CAN PLEASE GIVE BOTH A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE, WE WELCOME YOU TO
COME TAKE A PICTURE. WE ALSO
HAVE PROMINENT IRISH AMERICANS
WHO ARE UP IN THE GALLERY AS
WELL. WE WELCOME THEM TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. THANK
YOU. AND WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS. IF YOU LIKE TO TAKE A
PICTURE NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
RECONVENE IN 30 SECONDS.
OUR MEMBERS WERE RETURNING THE
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR, SENATOR
DALLY, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU. MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS IS MY
PLEASURE TO, UH, WELCOME THE
FOLSOM HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM
TO THE SENATE. THE FULSOME
BULLDOGS WON IN 2023, CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION STATE
FOOTBALL DIVISION ONE A
CHAMPIONSHIP IN AN EXCITING 20
TO 14 WIN OVER SAINT BORA HIGH
SCHOOL SAFRAS, WHICH IS LOCATED
LIONE'S DISTRICT, THIS FOLSOM
THIS IS FOLSOM'S FIFTH èC IF
STATE CHAMPIONSHIP, EARNING
STATE BANNERS IN 2010, 2014 2017
AND IN 2018. THESE ATHLETES
OFTEN BEGIN THEIR CAREER IN THE
FOLSOM JUNIOR BULLDOGS POP
WARNER PROGRAM AS YOUNG AS SIX
YEARS OLD. OVER SEVERAL YEARS.
COUNTLESS VOLUNTEERS, COACHES,
TEACHERS, PARENTS, UH, PEERS
THEIR TIME AND, UH, POURS THEIR
TIME AND SUPPORT INTO THESE
YOUNG MEN. EXCEL ON THE FIELD
AND IN THE CLASSROOM AND ARE THE
PRIDE OF THE FOLSOM COMMUNITY.
MANY GO ON TO PLAY FOOTBALL IN
COLLEGE AND IN THE  N FL. TWO
FOLSOM HIGH SCHOOL ALUMNI
CURRENTLY PLAY FOR THE
CINCINNATI BENGALS QUARTERBACK
JAKE BROWNING AND OFFENSIVE
TACKLE JONAH WILLIAMS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING THE
FOLSOM HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM
AND THEIR ACHIEVEMENT. THANK YOU
MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS AND WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE CENTER.
MEMBERS. SENATOR NILO FOR WHAT
PURPOSE? THANK YOU. EXCUSE ME.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH
FOLSOM, UM IS LUCKY TO HAVE NOT
ONE. BUT TWO STATE SENATORS. UH
I'VE REPRESENTED FOLSOM IN EVERY
PUBLIC OFFICE THAT I'VE HAD. I
LIVE IN FAIR OAKS, WHICH IS
RIGHT NEXT DOOR TO FOLSOM. SO
I'M VERY CLOSE TO THE COMMUNITY,
AND IT HAS BEEN FUN. I'LL
EMPHASIZE FUN FOLLOWING THE, UH
UH, THE PROGRESS OF THIS PROGRAM
OVER THE LAST, UH SEVERAL YEARS,
SO I SALUTE ALL THE YOUNG MEN OF
THAT TEAM AND COACH DOROTHY AND
HIS STAFF. UH AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU.
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS TO THE
FOLSOM HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
TEAM. THE ONE STATE CHAMPIONS
NEXT UP UNDER PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOOR, SENATOR ATKINS. FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MY OFFICE AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE 39TH
SENATE-DISTRICT TO RECOGNIZE MY
CHIEF OF STAFF. MY FRIEND, MY
ADVISOR NICK HARDIMAN. THIS WEEK
IS NICK'S LAST WEEK IN THE
SENATE, AND AS MUCH AS HE WANTED
TO QUIETLY SLIP OUT OF THE
CHAMBER DOOR. I COULDN'T LET
THAT HAPPEN, GIVEN THE
INCREDIBLE ROLE THAT HE HAS
PLAYED, ESPECIALLY IN THE SENATE
THESE LAST SIX YEARS. NICK IS
JOINED THIS MORNING BY HIS WIFE,
KATIE HARDIMAN, THEIR CHILDREN,
ALEX AND DAMIEN. HIS MOTHER,
MARINA HARDIMAN AND HIS BROTHER,
GREG HARDIMAN. AND IF YOU LOOK
AROUND, I SEE THAT MANY OF HIS
COLLEAGUES AND GOOD FRIENDS HAVE
JOINED US ON THE FLOOR IN THE
BACK AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
KATIE AND TO MARINA GREG, ALEX
AND DAMIEN. I WANNA THANK YOU
FOR SHARING NICK WITH US AND FOR
YOUR SACRIFICES AS HE HAS SERVED
24 HOURS A DAY, SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK AS CHIEF OF STAFF FOR ME,
PARTICULARLY THESE LAST SIX
YEARS. NICK HAS SERVED THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH HIS
WORK IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
FOR OVER TWO DECADES. I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN OVERSTATEMENT TO
SAY THAT EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM
HAS WORKED WITH NICK AND
EXPERIENCED HIS DEDICATION AND
HIS POSITIVE ATTITUDE. NICK GREW
UP IN SAN FRANCISCO IN A LABOR
HOUSEHOLD. HE WAS BIT BY THE
POLITICAL BUG AT A YOUNG AGE
SPEARHEADING A LIVING WAGE
INITIATIVE WHEN HE ATTENDED ST
MARY'S COLLEGE. HE ALSO PLAYED
RUGBY IN COLLEGE, WHICH HE
CREDITS AS EXCELLENT TRAINING
FOR CAMPAIGNS AND LEGISLATIVE
WORK. NICK FIRST CAME TO
SACRAMENTO AS A SENATE FELLOW
FOR THEN SENATOR RICHARD ACON.
HE STAYED ON AS A CONSULTANT
WITH THE SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE
BEFORE MOVING TO THE ASSEMBLY TO
WORK AS COMMUNICATIONS AND
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. FOR THEN,
UH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIONA MÀ
TREASURER WHO IS HERE WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU, TREASURER MÀ
FOR BEING HERE. HE WENT ON TO BE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS, UH, MASS.
CHIEF OF STAFF BEFORE JOINING
SPEAKER JOHN A. PEREZ'S OFFICE
TO FOCUS ON LABOR ISSUES. AND
THE SPEAKER IS WITH US TODAY AS
WELL. THANK YOU, SPEAKER PEREZ
FOR BEING HERE TO CELEBRATE NICK
WHEN I BECAME SPEAKER, I GOT TO
WORK WITH NICK MORE CLOSELY. I
WAS IMPRESSED BY HIS LIMITLESS
PASSION FOR THE WORK AND HOW HE
ALWAYS KEPT A LEVEL HEAD EVEN IN
THE MOST CHALLENGING SITUATIONS.
I LOBBIED NICK HARD WITH THE
HELP OF MY SPOUSE FOR HIM TO BE
MY CHIEF OF STAFF WHEN I CAME TO
THE SENATE WHEN I WAS ELECTED IN
2016. HE DID COME WITH ME. WHEN
I WAS SELECTED TO BE PRO TEM
NICK STEPPED UP AND PROVIDED
SUPPORT, NOT JUST FOR ME, BUT
FOR ALL OF THE MEMBERS IN THIS
CHAMBER, HE ACTED AS NEGOTIATOR,
A SUPPORT SYSTEM, A MORAL
COMPASS AND AS THE GLUE THAT HAS
KEPT MY TEAM IN THIS INSTITUTION
MOVING FORWARD. WE ENCOUNTERED
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES DURING OUR
TIME IN LEADERSHIP, INCLUDING
THE COVID-19 PANDEMIC, BUT
NICK'S WORK ETHIC AND DEDICATION
TO DECORUM NEVER WAVERED.
OVERALL, I WOULD SAY THREE
PERSONAL THINGS ONE I AM SURE
THAT I GOT THREE BOATS TO BECOME
PRO TEM ENTIRELY BECAUSE OF NICK
HARDIMAN. TWO NICK IS A SAN
FRANCISCAN THROUGH AND THROUGH
49ERS ALL THE WAY AND ONE OF MY,
UH, HIGHEST HONORS IS TO BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT GREAT CITY THROUGH
HIS EYES. THREE I TALKED ABOUT
HIM BEING LEVEL HEADED AND CALM.
THE MINUTE I HEARD NICK IN A
VERY QUIET VOICE SAY, OH, MY I
KNEW WE WERE IN TROUBLE. BUT FOR
AT THE HEART OF EVERYTHING. NICK
IS A PUBLIC SERVANT. AND I HAVE
APPRECIATED, UH, THE OPPORTUNITY
, UH, TO WORK WITH HIM, HE
STRIVED TO ENSURE THE SENATE AND
ITS STAFF WORK TOGETHER WITH
EFFICIENCY, COURTESY AND RESPECT
. HE'S BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE
FOR EQUITY, AND HE NEVER FORGETS
ABOUT THE UNDERDOG. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, HE BELIEVES GREATLY
IN SUPPORTING AND MENTORING
STAFF, AND I KNOW THAT MY OFFICE
AND THE SENATE HAVE BENEFITED
BECAUSE OF IT. I'M HAPPY TO SAY
THAT NICK WILL NOT BE LEAVING
THE STATE SERVICE COMPLETELY
TOMORROW. HE WILL TRAVEL TO
OAKLAND FOR HIS VERY FIRST
MEETING AS THE INAUGURAL CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA FAST FOOD
COUNCIL. GOVERNOR, YOU'RE
WELCOME. NICK I, OF COURSE, AND
ALL OF US WANT TO WISH YOU THE
BEST OF LUCK AND ALL YOUR FUTURE
ENDEAVORS. IT HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE HONOR AND A JOY TO
HAVE YOU AS MY CHIEF OF STAFF. I
AM PROUD OF WHAT WE HAVE ALL
ACHIEVED TOGETHER AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING ALL OF YOUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN THE NEXT
STAGE OF YOUR CAREER COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THANKING NICK
HARDIMAN FOR HIS SERVICE TO THE
SENATE TO CAPITOL COMMUNITY AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
AT THIS TIME, I'M GOING TO
RECOGNIZE THE MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO BRING REMARKS. MAJORITY
MINORITY LEADERS, JONES THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
RIGHT? TURN AROUND HERE LIKE NÓ.
MAYBE I'M MAYBE I'M NOT I. I
JUST WANNA SAY TO NICK AND HIS
FAMILY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR STATE. UH
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY AND
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH NICK,
SINCE, UH, WE WERE ALL BACK IN
THE ASSEMBLY TOGETHER. UH, WHEN
SENATOR ATKINS WAS THE SPEAKER,
AND EVEN BEFORE THAT. UH, NICK
HAS ALWAYS BEEN A PROFESSIONAL.
UH, HE'S ALWAYS FIERCELY FOUGHT
FOR THE LEADERS THAT HE'S WORKED
FOR, BUT ALSO AT THE SAME TIME
AS UH, SENATOR ATKINS, UH SAID,
UH, EVEN EVEN KILLED, MEASURED
AND FAIR, AND I KNOW THAT MY
STAFF IS GOING TO VERY MUCH MISS
WORKING WITH YOU. YOU'VE ALWAYS
BEEN VERY KIND AND CARING FOR MY
STAFF. AND WHEN THEY HAD A NEED
THAT YOU COULD SOLVE, YOU ALWAYS
DID. AND WE APPRECIATE THAT, UH,
AS BEFORE I GOT UP. I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW, FROM
SENATOR DALLY THAT YOU ARE, UH,
INVITED TO COME FISHING IN HIS
AREA ANY TIME THAT YOU CHOOSE
TO, I THINK WAS THE IT WAS AN
OPEN INVITATION. UH AND HE WOULD
LOVE TO HOST YOU. AND UH, MAYBE
I CAN SNEAK UP THERE TOO. UH,
WHEN THAT HAPPENS, BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY TO NICK, UH, THE
KIDS AND YOUR WIFE. UH, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE
TO BOTH HOUSES, THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE. AND TO TELL YOU THE
TRUTH, UH, I'M VERY EXCITED
ABOUT YOUR NEXT. UH, ASSIGNMENT.
I THINK THAT YOU ARE GONNA BE
VERY SERIOUS. ABOUT THAT. I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA BE AS UH, AS
FAIR AS ANYBODY COULD BE IN THAT
POSITION, AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THERE AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO MOVE CALIFORNIA
IN A IN A POSITIVE FASHION, SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
SENATOR LAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR PRESIDENT, AND IT IT
THE PRO TEM EMERITUS CANNOT BE
TOPPED AND THE APPLAUSE THAT WE
HEARD FROM EVERYBODY THAT WORKED
WITH HIM CANNOT BE TOPPED. BUT
EVEN THOUGH HE'S A SAN
FRANCISCAN, AND EVEN THOUGH HE
LIVES IN SACRAMENTO EVERY SUMMER
, HE HAS A DE FACTO RESIDENT OF
THE 17TH SENATE-DISTRICT. HE AND
HIS FAMILY COME AND SPEND TIME
IN CAPITOLA. HE HAS TAUGHT HIS
KIDS HOW TO FISH. HE ENJOYS THE
FOOD. HE ENJOYS THE BEACH
FRIENDS COME DOWN AND VISIT WITH
THEM. AND WE TRY TO GO OVER AND
HAVE DINNER AND WE HAD DINNER
THE YEAR BEFORE LAST, AND I
FOUND MYSELF LAST JANUARY,
TEXTING NICK AND SAYING, DID YOU
SEE PRESIDENT BIDEN STANDING IN
THE RESTAURANT WHERE WE HAD
DINNER LAST AUGUST? AND AS THE,
UH WAVES TOOK DOWN THE WHARF AND
SWAMPED ALL THE BUSINESSES I
HEARD FROM THE MAYOR? I HEARD
FROM THE CITY MANAGER AND I
HEARD FROM NICK. WHO WANT TO
KNOW WHAT THEY NEED. DO THEY
NEED HELP? AND WHEN HE WAS DOWN
THIS YEAR, I ARRANGED FOR A
BRIEFING OF THE MAYOR AND THE
CITY MANAGER TO EXPLAIN TO HIM
WHAT THE STATE HELP HAD DONE,
AND EXACTLY THE DIFFERENCE THAT
HE, ALONG WITH THE REST OF US
HAD MADE IN DOING THAT. SO EVEN
THOUGH HE HAS THIS INVITATION TO
FISH SOMEWHERE NAMELESSLY ON THE
NORTH COAST, HE WILL BE IN
CAPITOLA FIRST. AND I WILL ENJOY
IT. AND UH UH AND HE DOES THESE
THINGS IN A WAY THAT THEY'RE
UNSUNG, SO JUST ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS, THANK YOU FOR THE
HELP HE GAVE AND THE FACT THAT
HE BOOST TOURISM REVENUE EVERY
SUMMER. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SKINNER. SENATOR SKINNER YOU
RECOGNIZE? THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. AND UH, MEMBERS, UM,
AS SOMEONE WHO GREATLY RESPECTS
THIS INSTITUTION, IT IS ALWAYS
VERY BITTERSWEET. TO, UH, BE
HONORING NICK. IN WISHING HIM
WELL, BUT TO KNOW THAT HE IS
GONNA BE NÓ LONGER IN THE
EMPLOYEE OF THE LEGISLATURE. UM
NICK, YOU HAVE BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE ASSET TO THIS ENTIRE
INSTITUTION. AND AS YOU KNOW, I,
I GOT TO KNOW YOU WHEN YOU WERE,
UM, IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND, UH,
WHEN YOU WERE WORKING FOR, UH
UH, FIONA AND I WHEN FIONA WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TREASURER FIONA
AND I, UH, SERVED TOGETHER SO I
FIRST GOT TO KNOW NICK IN THAT
HAT. BUT THEN LATER WHEN HE WENT
TO WORK FOR, UH, SPEAKER PEREZ,
AS ARE PRO, TEMER POINTED OUT.
HE IS A CALMING INFLUENCE. AND
FOR THOSE OF US WHO WORKED WITH
MY GOOD FRIEND, UH FORMER
SPEAKER PEREZ, HE NEEDED
CALMING. AND THERE WEREN'T VERY
MANY PEOPLE WHO COULD DO IT. UM
SO ANYWAY, THERE'S MANY OTHER
THINGS I COULD SHARE. BUT JUST
GENERALLY. UM NICK, WE WILL MISS
YOU. I'VE BEEN A GREAT ASSET AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR Dð
RAZO. WOW. I CANNOT IMAGINE THIS
PLACE WITHOUT YOU, NICK. UM I
MET NICK WHEN I WAS HEAD OF THE
FEDERATION, UH AND, UH, LABOR
FEDERATION IN LOS ANGELES AND HE
WAS WORKING FOR SPEAKER PEREZ
AND WE HAD SOME REALLY TOUGH
ISSUES. BUT I ALWAYS REMEMBER
HOW CALM. NICK WAS, BUT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT HE DIDN'T
HAVE THE PASSION FOR WORKING
PEOPLE. AND THAT THAT HAS ALWAYS
STUCK WITH ME ABOUT THE WAY THAT
YOU ADDRESS ISSUES IS YOUR CALM.
YOU'RE STRONG. YOU'RE SMART, BUT
YOU'RE ALSO ALWAYS HAVE THE
PASSION OF WORKING PEOPLE IN
YOUR HEART. SO I ALSO WANNA
THANK YOUR FAMILY FOR ALLOWING
YOU TO DEVOTE SO MANY HOURS TO
US, AND I JUST WANNA REMIND
EVERYONE THAT WE ALSO HAVE
SOMETHING ELSE IN COMMON.
BESIDES OUR FAMILY HISTORY IN
THE LABOR MOVEMENT, AND THAT IS
WE ARE BOTH ALUMNI SAINT MARY'S
COLLEGE OF MORAGA. SO THANK YOU,
NICK FOR EVERYTHING ELSE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY, I
ALSO LIKE TO STAND AND RAISE AND
, UH AND SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT NICK. UH, I THINK
EVERYONE'S COVERED HIS
PROFESSIONALISM, WHICH I THINK
IT'S UNMATCHED. UH, THE WAY HE
TAKES CARE OF THE MEMBERS EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF US FEEL SPECIAL
BECAUSE YOU GIVE US THAT
PERSONAL ATTENTION, AND I KNOW
THAT I SAT MANY TIMES WITH YOU
WHERE YOU TAKE CARE OF ME AND
THAT'S INCREDIBLE BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THIS INSTITUTION IS
BETTER FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE HERE. BUT AS OUR Tð
EMERITUS STATUS. SHE GOT TO KNOW
SAN FRANCISCO THROUGH YOUR EYES.
SO TODAY I'M GONNA SHARE THAT. I
GOT TO KNOW YOU AS A FRIEND AS A
COMPADRE, HOW CARING YOU ARE,
HOW WELL YOU TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THIS INSTITUTION THROUGH
THE EYES OF CHRISTO MORENO,
WHO'S YOUR COMADRE? AND ALWAYS
TALK SO HIGHLY OF YOU, YOUR
FRIENDSHIP, YOUR DEDICATION TO
YOUR FAMILY, UH, TO THIS
INSTITUTION, THE THINGS YOU DO
WAY BEYOND THE COLOR OF DUTY
HERE THE HOURS THAT YOU IT IN
AND HOW THOUGHTFUL AND CARING
YOU ARE AND HER FRIENDSHIP WITH
KATIE AS WELL. AND I THINK ALL
OF US ARE GOING TO MISS YOU
GREATLY. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE, AND YOU WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ASHBY. I CAN SEE WE'RE ALL GONNA
MAKE OUR BEST. UH CLAIM ON MR
HARDIMAN HERE. I'M GONNA TRY MY
BEST TO WIN THAT COMPETITION.
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE PRO TEM
EMERITA. I KNOW THAT SHE LOVES
SAN FRANCISCO. AS WE ALL DO. BUT
THIS IS YOUR HOME. AND UH, I GET
TO BE YOUR SENATOR, AND I CAN
PROVE IT BECAUSE I GOT TO
WELCOME YOUR CHILDREN ONTO THIS
FLOOR WITH THEIR CLASSMATES. AND
I GOT TO STAND WITH YOU AS WE
PRESENTED CHECKS TO FAIRY TALE
TOWN AND TO SACRAMENTO STREET
SOCCER PROGRAM TO A MILLION
OTHER THINGS THAT YOU AND KATIE
AND YOUR CHILDREN HAVE POURED
YOURSELF INTO IN THIS CITY, AND
YOU ALL KNOW HIS WORK INSIDE OF
THESE WALLS MUCH BETTER THAN
EVEN I DO BECAUSE I'M NEW. BUT
WHAT YOU MIGHT NOT KNOW IS THAT
THIS THIS WHOLE FAMILY POURS
INTO THIS CITY. INCREDIBLY
WOMEN'S SOCCER. KATIE IS ONE OF
THEIR BIGGEST CHAMPION
SACRAMENTO STORM EXISTS. ONLY
BECAUSE OF SOME VERY STRONG
WOMEN WHO PUSH AND HIS WIFE IS
ONE OF THEM. AND NICK, AN
EXCELLENT HUSBAND NEVER FORGETS
AND STANDS RIGHT WITH HER TO
HELP ALL OF US. MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PROGRAMS STAY STRONG FOR
THE NEXT GENERATION. I KNOW YOU
WELL AND PERSONALLY, SO I KNOW
THAT THE BEST THING GOING FOR
YOU RIGHT IN THIS MOMENT IS THAT
LITTLE HAND THAT YOU'RE HOLDING?
THAT'S HOLDING YOU UP. BLESS HER
SWEETHEART FOR BEING HERE WITH
YOU AND BLESS YOUR FAMILY. AND
THEN ON JUST ONE PERSONAL NOTE,
NICK. IT'S REALLY HARD TO BE A
NEW SENATOR, ESPECIALLY IN
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE EVERYBODY
KNEW ME AND I COULDN'T REMEMBER
ALL OF THEM. BUT YOU HELPED ME
SO MUCH AND TOOK EVERY CALL I
EVER MADE TO YOU AND WALKED ME
THROUGH THE SIMPLE THINGS AND
THE COMPLICATED THINGS AND I
JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW DEEPLY
GRATEFUL AND APPRECIATIVE I AM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. WELL, NICK, I LOOK
BACK AT THE TIMES WE WERE
WALKING THE HILLS OF SAN DIEGO.
TOGETHER WE SPEND THE ENTIRE DAY
HUFFING AND PUFFING UP AND DOWN
THE SAN DIEGO HILLS FOR OUR
COLLEAGUE AND, UH AND I THINK
ABOUT I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THREE
WORDS THAT I THINK OF YOU DUTY
HONOR. COUNTRY. AND THAT IS NICK
. YOU KNOW YOUR LOVE OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY OF OURS, OUR
STATE. UH THE DEVOTION YOU GAVE
TO THE PRO TEM TO ALL OF US WHO
JUST WALKED IN THE DOOR. YOU YOU
MADE US FEEL LIKE WE BELONG. YOU
MADE US FEEL LIKE WE'RE GONNA BE
PART OF A BIG PICTURE, WHICH WE
ARE NOW AND, UH, YOU OPEN SOME
DOORS FOR US. BUT THE FACT THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT YOUR FAMILY
WHEN WE WERE WALKING TOGETHER,
SPEND THAT DAY TOGETHER. WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT MY FIVE KIDS. WE
TALKED ABOUT YOUR KIDS. WE
TALKED ABOUT YOUR FAMILY. BUT
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE LOVE YOU HAVE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO GOD BLESS YOU
FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE FOR ALL
OF US AS WE LOOK AROUND THE
ROOM, AND I AM NOT SURPRISED AT
THE PLA. THE GALLERY IS FILLED.
AND THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE HERE
TO SAY GOODBYE AND SAY THANK YOU
BUT AGAIN, GOD BLESS YOU AND
HAVE A GREAT TIME. THANK YOU,
SENATOR WEINER. THANK YOU, UH,
MR PRESIDENT, SO I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE SHOUTOUTS FOR THE
GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND
UH, ONCE TO SAN FRANCISCAN,
ALWAYS A SAN FRANCISCAN. UH AND
I KNOW SAN FRANCISCO IS ALWAYS
IN NEXT HEART. AND UH, I'M JUST
SO, UM, HONORED THAT THE, UH
HARDER AND FAMILY IS HERE. UH,
MY CONSTITUENTS. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO REPRESENT YOU. UM
I FIRST GOT TO KNOW THE HARDMAN
FAMILY. UH THROUGH, UH, NICK'S
DAD. UH, MIKE, GOD REST HIS
SOUL. UH, JUST, UH TREMENDOUS
HUMAN BEING, AS SHOWN BY HIS
FUNERAL, WHERE A MASSIVE CHURCH
WAS COMPLETELY, UH, PACKED. THE
HARDIMAN FAMILY IS CORE SAN
FRANCISCO AND, UM, THANK YOU FOR
ALL THAT. YOU DO, UH, FOR OUR
CITY, UM AND NICK, I ALSO JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT, UM UH, THE PRO
TEM? UH, EMERITA, UH, WAS, UH,
TRULY, UH, AMONG THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL LEADERS IN THIS
BUILDING, UH, EVER UH AND THIS.
THIS BODY IS SO WELL RESPECTED,
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH, UH AND DID
SO, UH, WITH VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS
WITH A LOT OF COLLABORATION AND
HARMONY, EVEN WHEN WE HAD
DISAGREEMENTS BECAUSE OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP, UH, CENTER ATKINS,
UM AND NICK, YOU WERE JUST SUCH
A KEY PART OF THAT. AND I WILL
TELL YOU AND I THINK YOU KNOW
THIS THE NUMBER WHEN I WHENEVER,
UM I WON'T SAY FIRST NAMES THE
SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO AND I
WOULD TALK AND YOU WOULD NOT
COME UP JUST THE EMOTION IN HER
VOICE BECAUSE OF HOW DEEPLY SHE
ADMIRES YOU, UH, AND LOVES YOU
AND YOU HAVE EARNED THAT 100
TIMES OVER. SO THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR
THIS INSTITUTION. THANK YOU.
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MISTER
PRESIDENT. UM ALL THIS. ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID REALLY
WONDERFUL THINGS THAT I JUST
ECHO, UH ACROSS THE BOARD, AND,
UM I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THAT
THE PEOPLE THAT SPOKE BEFORE ME
WERE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT YOU
ARE A NEGOTIATOR, A CALMER, A
PEACEMAKER. MOST OF ALL, YOU'RE
OUT OF THE BOX THINKER AND A
PROBLEM SOLVER. UM AND IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT SIDE OF THE
AISLE THAT YOU'RE ON. EVEN
THOUGH YOU WORK FOR THE SENATE
PRO TEM EMERITUS AND THE FORMER
SPEAKER. UM YOU ACTUALLY WORKED,
UM, OUTSIDE THE BOX TO HELP US
RESOLVE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THAT
ARE PERSONAL. TO US IN OUR
DISTRICT AND I SEE PREDECESSOR
UP THERE IN THE GALLERY. UH MR
CAMPBELL TO COME AND WATCH THIS.
UM THIS INCREDIBLE, UH, HONOR OF
YOU, AND, UM I DO WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT I THINK THAT YOU ARE
NOT ONLY ALL OF THOSE THINGS
THAT I MENTIONED BEFORE, BUT
YOU'RE AN INDIVIDUAL ON THE
STAFF AND IN THIS BODY AND IN
THIS INSTITUTION THAT HAS GREAT
INTEGRITY, AND I THINK THAT YOU
WILL CARRY THAT WITH YOU OR I
KNOW YOU'LL CARRY THAT WITH YOU.
WHATEVER YOU DECIDE TO DO. I
HOPE THAT YOU DO TAKE A VERY
LONG VACATION BECAUSE IT'S VERY
MUCH DESERVED AND I KNOW THAT,
UM WHEN YOU APPLIED FOR THESE
POSITIONS, EVERYTHING THAT YOU
DID WAS NOT IN THE JOB
DESCRIPTION THAT WAS POSTED BY
THE SENATE. I CAN 100% GUARANTEE
YOU. I REMEMBER CALLING YOUR
FORMER, UH, I REMEMBER CALLING
THE SENATE PRO TEM EMERITUS AND
SHE WAS OUT ON SOME HONDA SIDE
BY SIDE AND YOU GUYS WERE
TIPPING OVER SIDEWAYS ON THE
MOUNTAIN, GETTING A TOUR AND, UM
, THE ONLY THING THAT SHE COULD
THINK ABOUT IS OH, MY GOD,
NICK'S BACK THERE, AND HE'S GOT
HIS KIDS AT HOME. AND SO, UM, I
REMEMBER CALLING YOU TO GET SH
SIZES AND IF SHE WOULD GO
HORSEBACK RIDING, AND YOU WOULD
GET THESE SILLY QUESTIONS
ANSWERED FOR ME. SO EVEN ON A
PERSONAL NOTE, WHEN I WAS IN
LEADERSHIP, YOU WORKED SO WELL.
HAND IN HAND WITH MY STAFF WITH
MARK READER AND LINDSAY DIETZ
AND, UM, EVEN THOUGH YOU DIDN'T
HAVE TO, YOU MADE IT DECENCY AND
RESPECT BECAUSE I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE ONE PERSON
ONE OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS
BUILDING THAT RECOGNIZE THAT ALL
OF US ARE ELECTED TO REPRESENT
OUR DISTRICTS. AND EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY BE VASTLY DIFFERENT,
YOU DECENTLY RESPECT EVERY
MEMBER THAT IS HERE IN THE BODY.
AND EVERY CALIFORNIAN AND YOU
WILL BE GREATLY MISSED. AND MAY
GOD BLESS YOU ON EVERYTHING THAT
YOUR HAND TOUCHES IN THE FUTURE
AS YOU SEEK OUT WHATEVER YOU'RE
GOING TO DO, AND MAYBE
SUCCESSFUL WITH EVERYTHING THAT
YOU DO. THANK YOU. SENATOR
ALLEN. WELL, MEMBERS. I USUALLY,
UH HATE GETTING UP AND SPEAKING
WHEN EVERYTHING'S ALREADY BEEN
SAID ABOUT A TOPIC. BUT I'M
MAKING AN EXCEPTION FOR NICK
HARDIMAN, BECAUSE HE'S SUCH A
SPECIAL PERSON. UH SO YOU KNOW,
BEYOND BEING A GREAT DAD AND,
UH, A GOOD SOCCER DAD AND
HUSBAND, WHICH IS SOMETHING I
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE. UM I. I
JUST II. I DO WANNA SAY WHAT A
JOY HE'S BEEN TO WORK WITH. YOU
KNOW, THE MAJORITY LEADER AND I
WERE JUST SIDEBAR IT JUST NOW,
AND SHE MENTIONED THAT, UM, THAT
HE'S ALMOST LIKE, UH, ALL OF OUR
CHIEFS OF STAFF THAT HE WAS
SOMEBODY WE COULD SO AVAILABLE,
UH, SO ABLE TO SWITCH FROM
DIFFICULT ISSUE TO DIFFICULT
ISSUE AND SPEAK WITH
INTELLIGENCE AND THOUGHTFULNESS
ABOUT THIS MASSIVE RANGE OF
ISSUES THAT WE ALL HAVE TO DEAL
WITH, UH, WITH WITH WITH SUCH
ALACRITY AND, UM, I, I JUST I, I
GOTTA SAY THE GOOD NATURED, UH,
EVEN KILLED IN AN INCREDIBLE
PROBLEM SOLVER, WHICH IS REALLY
GOTTA BE ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT SKILLS IN THIS
BUILDING. AND SO, NICK, WE'RE
GONNA MISS YOU SO MUCH. YOU YOU
WE KNOW YOUR SERVICE CONTINUE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO PERSONALLY
THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
DONE TO HELP MAKE OUR SENATE
BETTER AND HELP MAKE ALL OF OUR
JOBS BETTER. I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU, NICK. THANK YOU. SENATOR
LAMONE. THANK YOU. AND UH, LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA.
I REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO KEEP
ADDING ON BUT, UM II. I FEEL
IT'S NEEDED. THIS IS THE MOMENT
TO RECOGNIZE YOUR INCREDIBLE
HARD WORK. UM I HAVE BEEN IN THE
ROOM WITH YOU WHERE IT HAPPENS,
AND WHEN IT HAPPENS AND YOUR
DEDICATION, YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE STATE TO LEADERSHIP TO OUR
PRO TEM EMERITA, UM, AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE VISION UH, WAS
ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT WAS
DELIVERED. YOU HAVE STAYED UP
TILL THE WEE HOURS OF THE
MORNING OF THE NIGHT DOING THE
WORK FOR CALIFORNIA. WHETHER
IT'S COMMA THAT IS BEING DEBATED
OR WHETHER THE OR WHETHER IT IS
SIGNIFICANT RIGHT
RECOMMENDATIONS. YOU HAVE BEEN
THERE, AND I THINK YOU'RE
HEARING FROM SO MANY MEMBERS
BECAUSE I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
WHAT ALL OF US HAVE EXPERIENCED
WITH YOU, BUT I ALSO BELIEVE
THAT IT IS AN INCREDIBLE TEAM.
WE'RE ON CAMERA RIGHT NOW
SPEAKING, BUT THERE ARE AN
INCREDIBLE TEAM. I'M LOOKING OUT
AT A TEAM THAT MAY BE THE PUBLIC
CAN'T SEE RIGHT NOW. WHO HAS ALL
BEEN THERE. IN THOSE MOMENTS WHO
HAS BEEN WHO HAVE BEEN AT THE
CHIEF OF STAFF MEETINGS WHO HAVE
BEEN THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
DOING THE BACKGROUND WORK ON
GETTING THE LEDGE. READY? THE
BUDGET READY? UH, AND YOU HAVE
BEEN THAT STEADY FORCE FOR SO
MANY OF US AND SO I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE YOU. AND THANK YOU, UM
, FOR ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE, IT HAS BEEN A PRIVILEGE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND LEARN FROM YOU
. UM AND I THINK I SAY THAT NOT
JUST FOR MEMBERS, BUT I SAY THAT
FOR MANY PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK. AND
YOU ALSO DID SOMETHING REALLY
INCREDIBLE. EVERY TIME THERE WAS
AN OUTRAGEOUS REQUEST FROM A
MEMBER, AND MAYBE THERE WAS JUST
A FEW IN YOUR LIFETIME. YOU JUST
MLED QUIETLY. SO THANK YOU, NICK
. FOR ALL OF THOSE MOMENTS, UM
AND THANK YOU FOR HOW DEDICATED
YOU ARE WHEN YOU WERE THERE AT
234 IN THE MORNING TRYING TO DO
THE WORK. UM IT MEANT THAT YOU
WEREN'T HOME WITH KATIE AND THE
KIDS. UM, BUT KATIE, YOU SHOULD
KNOW. THAT THE BEST THING HE DID
, AND WHEN HE FOUND HIS SMILE
WAS WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE WEEKENDS WITH SOCCER. SO UM,
AND ALL THE KID ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE HAPPENING, SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. UH, GOING TO TAKE THE
PHOTO.
AND I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AGAIN TO RECOGNIZE
OUR STATE TREASURER FIONA MÀ,
WHO'S HERE TODAY, AND SPEAKER
EMERITUS, JOHN PEREZ FOR BEING
HERE TO CELEBRATE IN THE
AQUARIUM AS WELL. ALLOW THEM TO
TAKE A PICTURE WITH THEM RIGHT
NOW.
MEMBERS IF YOU LIKE TO ENTER THE
PHOTO NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
SHOULD I GET IN?
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. WE WANT
TO CONGRATULATE NICK HARDIMAN.
WE WANT TO PERSONALLY. THANK YOU
, MR HARDIMAN FOR OVER TWO
DECADES OF SERVICE, AND I WANT
TO PERSONALLY THANK YOU FOR 15.
YEARS OF FRIENDSHIP. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
RECONVENE IN 30 SECONDS. WE'LL
RECONVENE IN 30 SECONDS.
WE'RE RETURNING BACK TO OUR
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR
LAIRD YOU RECOGNIZE? UH, THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. UH UH, IT'S
HARD TO FOLLOW THAT, BUT WE ARE
VISITED IN THE GALLERY BY
REPRESENTATIVES OF LEADERSHIP.
MORGAN HILL. THEY COME TO THE
CAPITOL EVERY YEAR. IN FACT,
FOUR YEARS AGO, THEY WERE HERE
ON THE DAY THAT THINGS WERE
LOCKED DOWN BECAUSE THEY
RELIGIOUSLY AT THIS TIME COME
EVERY YEAR LEADERSHIP. MORGAN
HILL DELIVERS A CURRICULUM TO
PEOPLE IN MORGAN HILL FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS THAT ARE
CHOSEN TO EDUCATE THEM ON
GOVERNMENT ISSUES AND JUST BEING
INVOLVED IN THE COMMUNITY. ITS
PARTICIPATION REPRESENTS A
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT FROM THE
PEOPLE. THERE ARE 12 CLASS
MEMBERS HERE TODAY. THEY'RE FROM
ALL WALKS OF LIFE AND MORGAN
HILL. THEY HAVE LEARNED A LOT
DURING THEIR VISIT. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WELCOMING THE CLASS OF
LEADERSHIP. MORGAN HILL. WELCOME
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE CENTER.
OUR MEMBERS WERE RETURNING BACK
TO OUR AGENDA. WE'RE ON FOLLOW
ITEM. SIX MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEAN RED.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED RED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. SENATOR
WEINER. YOU RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
, UH, I MOVE THE ADOPTION OF
AUTHORS. AMENDMENTS FOR BUDGET
BILLS LIKE ACROSS THE DESK ON
FRIDAY, SATURDAY AND SUNDAY
MARCH 15TH 16TH AND 17TH 2024.
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
, PUBLISHED AND THE BILL IS
RETURNED TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NILO. UH, QUESTION
OF THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. SO WE KNOW WHERE YOU
TAKE A QUESTION. AND BY THE WAY,
SENATOR I WAS BORN IN SAN
FRANCISCO. SO ONCE THE SAN
FRANCISCAN ALWAYS A SAN
FRANCISCAN. AMEN. UM WHERE CAN I
FIND A LIST OF THESE BILLS
IDENTIFIED TODAY? UH, THEY WILL
BE, UH, WHEN THEY GO INTO PRINT,
UH, THEY'LL BE AVAILABLE AND
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE THEM. SO
VOTING ON THIS TODAY. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT BILLS THEY ARE WILL BE
. THE BILLS WILL HAVE TO BE
VOTED ON. THIS IS NOT VOTING ON
THE MERITS OF THE BILL. THIS IS
ABOUT THE BILLS GOING, BUT IN
TERMS OF TODAY'S VOTE YEAH,
THEY'RE NOTED IN THE FILE AND,
UH WE'RE VOTING TO ALLOW THEM TO
BE AMENDED. THANK YOU FOR THAT
NOW. AS EVERYBODY IN HERE KNOWS,
UH, WELL, I GUESS TO QUOTE UH,
UH, TO SHARE A GREAT QUOTE FROM
A PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE OF A, UH,
A FORMER PRESIDENT, WHO WAS ALSO
A FORMER GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF YOU OLDER WILL REMEMBER
THIS. OH THERE YOU GO AGAIN, SO
BUT BUT WE'RE TAKING IT ONE STEP
FARTHER, UH, IN PAST TIMES, UH,
THE BILLS HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
WHEN WE'VE VOTED TO AUTHORIZE
THIS IN THE FIRST PLACE. UM AND
WE'RE AUTHORIZING AMENDMENTS TO
BE MADE, WHICH, THEORETICALLY,
IS A CARTE BLANCHE TO BASICALLY,
UM, UH, CHANGE ANY BILL THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN THE SENATE. I'M NOT
MAKING THE ACCUSATION THAT
THAT'S WHAT THE PLAN IS. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT UH
UH, IF THIS IS APPROVED, THAT'S
THE AUTHORITY THAT YOU'RE VOTING
, UH, TO GIVE, AND, UM I
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM
WITH THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY OF
THIS PRO, UH, PROCESS AS WE'VE
EXERCISED IT IN THE PAST, BUT AS
I SAID, THIS TAKES IT ONE STEP
FARTHER. THAT I THINK IS VERY UN
UNWISE PRECEDENT FOR THIS
INSTITUTION, SO I URGE A NÓ
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HERE IN èC
?  N. SENATOR WEINER. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? UH, YES. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT, UH, WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMMENTS THAT
WHICH HAS MADE JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE FIRST THE BILLS ARE NOTED IN
THE FILE. IN ADDITION, THIS IS
SIMPLY ALLOWING FOR AMENDMENTS.
SO UH, WE AMEND BILLS ALL THE
TIME AND THEN THERE IS A 72 HOUR
RULE COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND A
NEW VOTE ON THEM. THIS IS JUST
ALLOWING FOR AMENDMENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU. I DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR WINNERS ASKING FOR I
VOTE, SENATOR NEAL IS ASKING FOR
A NÓ VOTE. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OUR HØI. I WROTE
A DEAL. I ARCHULETA I ASHBY I
ATKINS I BECKER BY BLAKESPEAR.
BY BRADFORD I. CABALLERO. I,
CORTEZ. I DALLY. NÓ DODD. HIYO.
HØI EGM. GLASER. HØI GONZALEZ. I
GROWTH. NÓ HURTADO. I. JONES. NÓ
LAD. I LIMÓN AY MCGUIRE HØI
MINAR. MEN. I NEWMAN AYE. WIN.
NE WHEN NILO. NÓ. NÓ IY
PORTANTINO. AYE, ROTH. HØI
RUBIO. I SAY ARTO. NÓ SKINNER.
HØI SMALL QUIVERS A STERN HØI
HUMBERG. AYE, WAHAB. HØI WEINER.
I WILL NÓ. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MENJIVAR. AYE.
WHEN NÓ AYS 32. KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MOTION CARRIES. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILES. SECOND READING
ITEMS 12 THREE, UH, SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 927 WITH
AMENDMENTS 1004 WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL 1770. THANK YOU.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR GROVE.
GOVERNANCE APPOINTMENTS. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. THANK YOU, MAYOR.
MR PRESIDENT. P ITEM NUMBER FOUR
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR UH
, ASIF MAHD FOR THE
REAPPOINTMENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE? UH, MEDICAL BOARD DOCTOR
MAD, APOLOGIZE FOR
MISPRONOUNCING HIS NAME. DR
MAHMOUD IS A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN, AND HE'S A FOUNDER
AND DIRECTOR OF, UM PULMONOLOGY
AND HOSPITALIST ASSOCIATES, AND
HE'S THE FIRST APPOINTED AND WAS
THE FIRST APPOINTED TO THE
MEDICAL BOARD IN 2019. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON SIX FOR THE 50 VOTE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT, SENATOR MAN? THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
APPOINTMENT OF DR ASIF MAHMOUD
TO THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. UH, I GOT TO KNOW
DOCTOR MAHMOUD A FEW YEARS BACK.
HE HAS ROOTS IN ORANGE COUNTY.
UH AND HE HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
PUBLIC SERVICE. I I THINK LAID
OUT BY MY COLLEAGUE OVER THERE,
BUT, UH UH, THE ONE THING I JUST
WANT TO NOTE IS HIS PASSION AND
DEDICATION TO HELPING OTHERS.
UH, IT IT IT REALLY INFORMS HIS
WHOLE BODY OF WORK. AND SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING HIS
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU SEEING NÓ
FURTHER MICS UP, SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FOUR. ALAN AYE, I WROTE A
GULL. AYE, ARCHULETA, HØI ASHBY.
I, ATKINS I BECKER AYE
BLAKESPEAR IY BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. UH, CORTEZ. HØI
DALLY. DODD. HØI EGM. I GLASER.
HØI GONZALEZ. I DROVE I HURTADO.
I. JONES. LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. I
MAGUIRE. HØI MINAR. MEN. AYE,
NEWMAN. I WIN. MILO. HØI AYE,
BUT YOU HØI TINO. AYE, ROTH. HØI
RUBIO. I SAY ARTO. SKINNER. I
SMOKE QUAVERS. I STERN I HUMBERG
IW. WEINER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MENJIVAR.
AYE. WHEN WELL. OURS 38 NÓ ZERO.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIVE.
THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM FIVE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DR RICHARD
THORPE FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF
THE MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA
DOCTOR THORPE IS CURRENTLY A
PHYSICIANS, UM, SUPERVISOR FOR
THE PARADISE MEDICAL GROUP,
WHERE HE PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS
PRESIDENT. èC E Ó FOLLOWING,
UM, THE CAMPFIRE. HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
IN 2019. HE WAS AGAIN APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SIXTH RESPECTFULLY BY UNANIMOUS
VOTE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE EMPLOYMENT HERE
IN XIN, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. AYE, I RO. YOU. AYE,
ARCHULETA, HØI ASHBY. IY ATKINS
I BECKER HØI BLAKESPEAR. I,
BRADFORD. I CABALLERO HØI
CORTEZ. HØI DALLY. HØI DODD. I,
TOO HØI EGM. I GLASER. AYE
GONZALEZ. I GROVE. I TOO JONES.
I LAYERED HØI LEMON. I MAGUIRE.
AYE. BEAR. AYE MIN. HØI NEWMAN.
HØI WHEN HIY NILO. I A èC B.
PER DIEM. HØI PINO. AYE. ROTH.
HØI RUBIO. I SAY ARE TO I.
SKINNER. AYE, SMALL CUEVAS. I
STERN HØI UMBERG. AYE, WAHAB.
WEINER. I WILKE POLICE CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS. WELL. I 39 NÓ
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN. SENATOR
BUREAU. THANK YOU. MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM SEVEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF NIKKI
BEASLEY FOR THE APPOINTMENT TO
THE HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CORPORATION, OR COOPER OPERATION
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. MS BEASLEY
SERVES AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR RICHMOND NEIGHBORHOOD
HOUSING SERVICES AND PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS A BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
DIRECTOR FOR AT YOUTH, UM,
UPRISING. SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH 6TH
ON A 50 VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR AN I VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCRETION IS MADE ON THE
APPOINTMENT HERE IN XAN
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. HØI OF ROGI. I ARCHULETA
I ASHBY IY ATKINS. I BECKER AYE,
BLAKESPEAR I BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO. UH, CORTEZ. AY DALLY
DONE. AYE, THE RAZZO. HØI EDWIN.
I GLASER. AY GONZALEZ I GROVE. I
REDO. I. JONES. I HAVE LAYERED
HØI LEMON, I MAGUIRE AYE. M YOU
BY HØI M. AYE, NEWMAN. AYE. WIN.
HØI NILO. I, OCHO. HØI I
WOULDN'T YOU KNOW. I BROUGHT HØI
RUBIO. AYE. SAY ARTO. HØI
SKINNER. HØI SMALL QUIVERS. I
STERN HØI AMBERG. HØI WAHAB.
AYE, WIENER. I WILL. I PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER. DALLY.
HØI. HE'S 40 KNOWS ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE TWO
ITEMS THERE, ITEM 10. SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ. IN BILL 477 BY
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING AND A TO
LAND USE AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR. SENATOR
SKYNYRD FLOORS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. THIS IS
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE'S, UH,
COMMITTEE BILL. IT IS CLEAN UP
ON SOME A Dð U, UH, PASSED
LEGISLATION. IT WAS HELD UNTIL
THIS SESSION, SO TO AVOID
CHAPTER OUT ON SOME BILLS THAT
WERE PASSED LAST YEAR AND SIGNED
, THERE ARE NÓ POLICY OR
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES. IT WAS, UH,
IT'S ENTIRELY TECHNICAL CLEANUP,
AND IT'S ALSO AN URGENCY MEASURE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TO AVOID ISSUES FOR
ANY BILLS THIS YEAR. AND WITH
THAT, I WOULD LIKE YOUR I VOTE.
MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A ANNOUNCED ROLL CALL
ON THIS MEASURE? IN SCENE NÓ
EYES 40. ON THE URGENCY, NÓ ZERO
ON THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM 11. SENATOR Dð RAZZO.
PLEASE, SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
TH BILL 479 BY SENATOR DE RAZO
AND AQUIL TO TENANCY AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THEREOF TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR
ROS OF FLORIDA IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO S¼ B 479 ARE
TECHNICAL AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
IN NATURE. THEY ARE SMALL, CLEAN
UP TO MY S¼ P 567 FROM LAST YEAR
AND ADD URGENCY SO THAT THIS
REVISION CAN BE MADE PRIOR TO S¼
B 567 GOING INTO EFFECT IN APRIL
. THIS MEASURE IS SUPPORTED BY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES AND
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. IT RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND IN THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE.
REMEMBERS THIS, TOO, IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING TO
UN UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEE NÓ
OBJECTION. AYS 40 ON THE URGENCY
. THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN 40 0. NOW MEMBERS
WERE MOVING ON TO SENATE THIRD
READING. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS.
FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM 18. AND WE
HAVE SENATOR. SHE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. CYNIC
AND CURRENT RESOLUTION 118 BY
SENATOR WAHAB RELATIVE TO
BLEEDING DISORDERS AWARENESS
MONTH. SOON WILL HOP. THANK YOU,
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT S¼ èC R 118, WHICH
PROCLAIMS MARCH 2024 AS BLEEDING
DISORDERS AWARENESS MONTH.
HEMOPHILIA IS A RARE GENETIC
CONDITION AFFECTING AT LEAST
4000 PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA VON
WILLEBRAND DISEASE IMPACTS AT
LEAST THREE 160,000 PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT TREATMENT.
PEOPLE WITH RARE BLEEDING
DISORDERS FACE FREQUENT AND
SPONTANEOUS BLEEDING EPISODES
INTO THEIR JOINTS, CAUSING
SWELLING PAIN AND JOINT DAMAGE.
LACK OF TREATMENTS AND OTHER
MEDICATIONS CAN LEAD TO CHRONIC
ARTHRITIS, PERMANENT DISABILITY,
CHRONIC PAIN AND FREQUENT
HOSPITALIZATIONS WITHOUT THE
THEY NEED. MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE AT RISK OF
SEVERE BLEEDING AND EVEN DEATH
WITH PROPER CARE ACCESS TO
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED HEMOPHILIA
TREATMENT CENTERS AND WITH NEWER
CLOTTING FACTOR MEDICATIONS,
PATIENTS CAN NOW EXPECT TO HAVE
A FULL LIFE EXPECTANCY BY
DECLARING MARCH 2024 BLEEDING
DISORDERS AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE EDUCATING
REDUCING DISCRIMINATION AND
FOSTERING UNDERSTANDING OF
HEMOPHILIA AND OTHER RARE
BLEEDING DISORDERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM AND DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE IN CHINA MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
MEASURE HERE IN SINA? I S¼ 40 NÓ
ZERO. THE MEASURE IS APPROVED.
NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 23
SENATOR RUBIO. SHE'S PREPARED
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ. IN A
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. 122 BY
SENATOR RUBIO BE TO JUSTICE RUTH
BADER GINSBURG DAY. SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT A
WOMAN'S CAUCUS RESOLUTION. S¼
èC R 122, WHICH PROCLAIMS MARCH
1520 24 AS JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG'S DAY IN CALIFORNIA
NEARLY FOUR YEARS AGO ON
SEPTEMBER 1820 20. WE WERE
DEVASTATED TO HEAR OF THE
PASSING OF JUSTICE GINSBURG
AFTER A LONG BATTLE WITH CANCER
AS WE HONOR HER LIFE AND LEGACY,
LET CELEBRATE HER FOR BEING A
VIBRANT GUARDIAN OF EQUALITY FOR
ALL. IT WAS THROUGH HER
LITIGATION, COMMUNITY OUTREACH,
ADVOCACY AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
THAT JUSTICE GINSBURG EMPOWERED
POOR WOMEN. WOMEN OF COLOR
IMMIGRANT WOMEN, THE L GB Tð Q
COMMUNITY. WHO HAVE BEEN SUBJECT
TO GENDER BIAS AND WHO HAVE
FACED PERVASIVE BARRIERS AND
EQUALITY. SHE BROKE THROUGH MANY
GLASS CEILINGS FOR ALL OF US. BY
GRADUATING FIRST IN HER CLASS
FROM COLUMBIA LAW, BECOMING THE
FIRST FEMALE PROFESSOR TO EARN
TENURE AT COLUMBIA LAW SCHOOL,
SERVING AS THE FIRST FEMALE
MEMBER OF THE HARVARD LAW REVIEW
AND COLUMBIA LAW REVIEW AND
LATER BECOMING THE SECOND WOMAN
APPOINTED TO THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT. SHE LEFT A
PROFOUND MARK ON AMERICAN
HISTORY. AND WORK TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE AND THEIR FAMILIES
COULD ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF FULL
EQUALITY AND PARTICIPATE IN
EVERY SPHERE OF SOCIETY,
INCLUDING HER LANDMARK CASE.
UNITED STATES VERSUS VIRGINIA,
WHICH ENDED GENDER SEGREGATION
IN PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS, AND SET
THE PRECEDENT FOR EVERY GENDER
EQUITY VICTORY THAT FOLLOWED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE OVERTURN OF
ROE VERSUS WADE COSTS MANY
STATES TO STRIP AWAY AN
ESSENTIAL RIGHT FOR ALL WOMEN.
AND TO HONOR HER LEGACY. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT AS A NATION, WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD AND NOT
BACKWARDS AND PROTECTING WOMEN'S
RIGHTS, SOMETHING SHE WORKS SO
HARD TO ACHIEVE. JUSTICE
GINSBURG IS PRESENT IN THE
PRESENCE IN THE COURT. PRESERVE
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO CHOOSE AND SHE
UNDERSTOOD VERY PERSONALLY. WHEN
GOVERNMENT TRIES TO CONTROL
WOMEN'S DECISIONS. WOMEN ARE
TREATED LESS THAN A PERSON IN
THIS COUNTRY. LESS THAN AN ADULT
CAPABLE OF MAKING THEIR OWN
DECISIONS. TODAY WE RECOGNIZE
AND HONOR JUSTICE GINSBURG FOR
HER COMMITMENT AND DEDICATION TO
ALL I WOULD LIKE TO END WITH ONE
OF MY FAVORITE QUOTES FROM
JUSTICE GINSBURG PERMISSION TO
READ. MISTER GRANITE. THANK YOU.
WOMEN'S RIGHTS ARE AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE OVERALL HUMAN RIGHTS
AGENDA. TRAIN ON THE EQUITY,
EQUAL DIGNITY AND ABILITY TO
LIVE IN FREEDOM ALL PEOPLE
SHOULD ENJOY WITH THAT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE, SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FOR, UM AUTHORING IT
AND I ALSO THANK HER FOR AS YOU
NOTICED THAT MANY OF THE, UH
WOMEN MEMBERS OF THE FLOOR TODAY
ARE WEARING COLLARS LIKE THE, UH
UH, OUR FORMER JUSTICE, UH, RUTH
GATOR BINS. BADER GINSBURG ALSO
OBVIOUSLY WORE, UM WHEN SHE WAS
AT THE BENCH, AND SHE WORE
DIFFERENT COLORS FOR DIFFERENT
PURPOSES. BUT I RISE NOW BECAUSE
ONE OF HER SIGNIFICANT BEFORE
SHE WAS SUPREME COURT JUSTICE,
BUT ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT CASES
THAT SHE ARGUED BEFORE THE COURT
, WHICH IS WELL KNOWN, WAS ON
THE BASIS OF SEX AND LAID OUT
THE, UH THE PRECEDENCE IS AROUND
MORE EQUAL, UH, TO GET AT THIS
DISPARATE TREATMENT THAT A
GENDER BIAS MEANT THAT WOMEN
EXPERIENCED UNDER THE LAW. UM
NOW IT WAS VERY SIGNIFICANT.
THAT GROUNDBREAKING RULING THAT
SHE GOT AND OTHER RULINGS WHEN
SHE WAS ON THE COURT THAT SHE
HERSELF PARTICIPATED IN. AND YET
HERE WE ARE TODAY. IT'S 2024.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH AND I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY OF YOU NOTICED THE
HEADLINE. I BELIEVE IT WAS
YESTERDAY AND THERE WERE, IT WAS
HEADLINES ALL OVER ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA MOM. CALIFORNIA MOM
ARRESTED FOR BEING THE
RINGLEADER OF THE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT. NOW THE CRIME
THAT'S WAS THE ARREST WAS MADE
FOR AND THAT THIS PARTICULAR
PERSON WAS ACCUSED OF IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND SOMETHING WE'RE
ALL PAYING ATTENTION TO, BUT YOU
READ THROUGH THE ARTICLE, AND
YOU NOTE THAT HER HUSBAND WAS
ALSO PART OF THE OPERATION, AND
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE FACTS YET,
BUT PERHAPS, UH, EQUAL PARTNER
IN THE OPERATION. UM ALSO THE
FATHER OF HER CHILDREN, DID THE
HEADLINE SAY CALIFORNIA DAD
ARRESTED AS RINGLEADER. YOU KNOW
DID, UH AND ALSO, WHAT DOES IT
HAVE TO DO WITH ANYTHING THAT
SHE'S A MOM? SO WE HAVEN'T GONE
VERY FAR. I HOPE WE DO. AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? SENATOR SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. UH,
MR PRESIDENT AND GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES AND I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 122 THAT
RECOGNIZES MARCH 15TH AS JUSTICE
RUTH BADER GINSBURG DAY JUSTICE.
GINSBURG WAS A TRUE TRAILBLAZER
WHO DEDICATED HER LIFE TO THE
PURSUIT OF EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY FOCUSING HER ENERGY
AND BRILLIANCE ON WOMEN, BUT
ALSO ON BLACK AMERICANS. IN
OTHER CITIZENS FROM MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. HER COMMITMENT TO
EQUALITY WAS MARKED BY HER
COURAGEOUS DECISIONS AND
DISSENTS ON THE SUPREME COURT ON
ISSUES RANGING FROM VOTING
RIGHTS, AFFIRMATIVE ACTION,
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
AND FAIR EMPLOYMENT IN 2003 WHEN
THE VOTING RIGHTS ACT ONE OF THE
MOST ACCOM, ONE OF ONE OF THE
GREATEST ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THIS
COUNTRY, IN TERMS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AND CREATING ACCESS AND
CONNECTIONS FOR EVERY CITIZEN TO
PARTICIPATE. THIS DEMOCRACY WAS
THREATENED AND GUTTED. IT WAS
JUSTICE GBG GINSBURG, WHO
DOCUMENTED THE RACIST TACTICS OF
VOTER SUPPRESSION AND
INTIMIDATION AND OUTLINE THE
TARGETING OF BLACK VOTERS AND
FOUGHT TO ENSURE THAT THERE WAS
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX.
SHE ALSO DEFENDED THE INTRINSIC
RIGHTS OF AFFIRMATIVE ACTION,
RECOGNIZING THAT WE MUST MANDATE
THAT ALL PEOPLE BE REPRESENTED
IN SCHOOLS AND WORK SITES IN
CONTRACTS. SHE PROFOUNDLY
UNDERSTOOD HOW IT IS ESSENTIAL
FOR THIS TOOL TO ADDRESS THE
HISTORIC INJUSTICES AND
EXCLUSION BOTTLED IN THIS
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM THAT HAD
SEEPED INTO SO MANY FACETS OF
OUR SOCIETY, AND THAT THE ONLY
WAY WE COULD DEAL WITH THIS WAS
TO USE THE TOOL OF JUSTICE AND
THE LAW AND HOW IT WAS NECESSARY
THAT WE PROMOTE AND MANDATE
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION IN ALL
OF OUR INSTITUTIONS. SHE
DEFENDED AFFIRMATIVE ACTION
AGAINST LEGAL ATTACK, SHE STOOD
UP AND REMINDED AMERICANS THAT
THAT BLACK AMERICANS AND WOMEN
HAVE THE RIGHT TO BE IN EVERY
WORK SITE AND INSTITUTION IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND THAT THEY
BENEFITED THEY MEANING ALL OF
THE COUNTRY. ALL AMERICANS, BE
IT FOR THE PRACTICE OF
INCLUSION. WHEN FACED WITH
INTENSE EFFORTS TO DESTROY THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT THAT WAS LED
BY AMERICA'S FIRST BLACK
PRESIDENT, IT WAS RUTH BADER
GINSBURG THAT SPOKE ABOUT THE
HEALTH DISPARITIES OF BLACK
AMERICANS WHO LIFTED UP HOW
THESE DISPARATE HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND MORTALITY RATES WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY WORSE IN BLACK
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT AMERICA
HAD TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
SHE DEFENDED THIS ACT BY
INVOKING THE CONSTITUTIONAL
POWERS OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO PROTECT THE BEING OF ALL
AMERICANS AND THEIR ACCESS TO
LIFE THROUGH HEALTH CARE. SHE
ALSO USED HER INFLUENCE TO
PROTECT WORKING PEOPLE FROM WAGE
DISCRIMINATION STOOD UP ON THE
ECONOMIC PLIGHT OF WOMEN IN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE WAYS IN WHICH
WOMEN AND BLACK WORKERS WERE
PAID IN THIS COUNTRY AND ENSURED
THAT A WOMAN COULD HAVE, UH AS
THE RIGHT TO TAKE AS LONG AS SHE
NEEDS TO CARE FOR HERSELF,
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT CAME TO,
UH, MATERNITY LEAVE, UH, IN THE
WORKPLACE. IN FAIRNESS, UM AS
PERTAIN TO THE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT, UH, RELATED
TO WHITE MEN IN THIS COUNTRY IN
THE WORKPLACE, SHE USED HER
VOICE AND HER VOTE TO DIRECT
CONGRESS ON A PATH TO PUTTING
WAGE PROTECTIONS IN PLACE. AND
BENEFITS IN PLACE THAT PROTECTED
ALL OF US AND THAT'S WHY WE WEAR
THESE NECKLACES TODAY. THAT'S
WHY WE CELEBRATE HER LIFE. THIS
UH TODAY. THAT'S WHY WE
CELEBRATE HER INFLUENCE ON OUR
GOVERNMENT AND OUR LAWS AND
CONTINUE THE UNFINISHED WORK OF
JUSTICE FOR ALL IN THIS COUNTRY
AND WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY CALL
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM HERE IN QINAN RUBIO,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I JUST
WANNA THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR THEIR WORDS. AND WITH
THAT, I URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM. 20 THREE.
ALAN AYE. I WROTE A GULL. AYE,
ARCHULETA. I ASHBY. I ATKINS I
BECKER HØI BLAKESPEAR HØI
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
AYE, DALLY. BUT AYE, THE RAZO
HØI EGM. GLASER. GONZALEZ. HIGH
GROWTH. HURTADO. HØI JONES. HØI
LAYERED AYE. LEMON. UH, HØI
MCGUIRE. HØI M JAR. AYE MIN. I
NEWMAN AYE. WIN. NILO. HØI
PATROL BOAT. IP I FOR LATINO. IW
HØI RUBIO. I SAY ARTO. DINNER.
AYE, SMALL CUEVAS. BY STERN. HØI
UMBERG. W. WIENER. AYE. WELCOME.
I PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DALLY. GROWTH. WHEN
THEY ARE TO WILL HAVE AYE. I 36
KNOW ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
AND MEMBERS AT THE END OF
SESSION, THERE WILL BE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PHOTO OP. ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBERS. NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM. 26
SENATOR HURTADO, ARE YOU
PREPARED? SHE IS SECRETARY YOU
MAY READ. SENATE RESOLUTION 70
THREE BY SENATOR HURTADO
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL DAY. IN TOO THANK
YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ R 73, WHICH MAKES
UH, TUESDAY, MARCH 19TH AG DAY.
UM OVER MEMBERS OVER 12,000
YEARS AGO, AGRICULTURE MARKED A
PROFOUND SHIFT FROM NOMADIC
HUNTER GATHERER LIFESTYLES TO
SETTLED COMMUNITIES. TODAY
FARMING IS A GLOBAL INDUSTRY
WITH NUMEROUS IMMIGRANTS
CARRYING THEIR PROFESSIONS TO
THEIR NEW HOMES. AND ON MARCH
19TH. WE EXPRESSED DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE DEDICATION
OF OUR FARMERS, FARM WORKERS AND
ALL INDIVIDUALS CONTRIBUTING TO
THE AGRICULTURAL FOOD SYSTEM.
RECOGNIZING THE INDISPENSABLE
LINK BETWEEN AGRICULTURE AND
NUTRITION. WE UNDERSCORE ITS
PIVOTAL ROLE IN SAFEGUARDING OUR
HEALTH. ADDITIONALLY WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FORMIDABLE
CHALLENGES CONFRONTED BY THOSE
WITHIN THE AG SECTOR. DESPITE
THE CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
SECTOR, LET US REMAIN STEADFAST
IN OUR SUPPORT FOR FARMERS, FARM
WORKERS AND ALL INVOLVED IN THE
AGRIFOOD SYSTEM THE SIGNIFICANCE
OF THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES ALONE KEEPS 22
MILLION PEOPLE EMPLOYED WITH
EACH AMERICAN FARMER PROVIDING
FOOD TO 100 AND 44 PEOPLE.
TOGETHER LET US WORK TOWARDS
SOLUTIONS THAT ENSURE THE
RESILIENCE AND SUSTAINABILITY OF
OUR FOOD PRODUCTION SYSTEMS WITH
COLLECTIVE EFFORT AND INNOVATION
. WE CAN OVERCOME OBSTACLES AND
BUILD A BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR
AGRICULTURE AND FOOD SECURITY
WORLDWIDE. SO COME ON OUT ON UH,
AG DAY TUESDAY, MARCH 19TH AND
LEARN ABOUT AGTECH CHECK OUT THE
ANIMALS SEE JOHN DEERE'S LATEST
AND GREATEST TRACTORS AND PICK
UP SOME FLOWERS, UH, AG DAY WILL
BE HELD ON THE WEST STEPS OF THE
CAPITOL ONCE AGAIN. ON THE 19TH
OF THIS MONTH. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING YOU THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE, SENATOR DOWLEY.
MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I LOVE
THIS RESOLUTION EVERY YEAR. I
LOVE TO GET UP AND TALK ABOUT
AGRICULTURE IN CALIFORNIA AS A
THIRD GENERATION FARMER MYSELF,
UM, 90 THREE YEARS OUR FAMILY'S
BEEN IN CALIFORNIA PRODUCING
FOOD AND FIBER FOR, UH ONLY
CALIFORNIANS, BUT FOR THE WORLD.
I JUST WANNA SAY THAT, UH,
CALIFORNIA LEADS IN THIS AREA.
UM BY FAR NOWHERE IN THE WORLD.
DO WE HAVE THE SAFEST? UH MORE
PRODUCTION PER ACRE? UH, WE HAVE
THE RIGHT. UH, I THINK GOD LAID
OUT CALIFORNIA IN A WAY. THAT'S
JUST AMAZING. WE HAVE THE
PACIFIC WITH THE STORMS COME IN.
WE HAVE THE SES THAT CATCH THE
SNOW. THAT WATER COMES DOWN INTO
OUR FERTILE SOILS IN THE
VALLEYS. UM, BUT I WANNA JUST
SAY, UH, THIS YEAR SINCE IT'S
THE LAST TIME I GET TO SPEAK ON
THIS IS THAT AGRICULTURE IN
CALIFORNIA IS A TOUGH BUSINESS.
WE SAW THE BIGGEST, UH, COMPANY.
HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
GO BANKRUPT HERE JUST RECENTLY
IN AMMONS, UH, AND THAT'S
BECAUSE, UM, WE'RE SEEING BIG
INVESTMENT CORPORATIONS COME IN.
AND THE FAMILY FARM. UH WHICH IS
WHAT WE OPERATE, UM, IS GETTING
SQUEEZED OUT BY A LARGE FARMS
AND, QUITE FRANKLY, IT'S DUE TO
REGULATION TOO. UH, MY
GRANDFATHER CAME IN. 1929 HAD
SEVEN CHILDREN HIRED PEOPLE TO
RUN OUR FARM. UH, MEGAN AND I
RUN THAT SAME FARM TODAY WITH
THREE PEOPLE. AND WE HAVE OTHER
LANDS THAT WE HAVE TO, UH,
EXPAND INTO BECAUSE THE COST OF
EQUIPMENT AND THE REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA FARMERS
ARE PAYING A DOLLAR A GALLON
HIGHER FOR DIESEL. THEY'RE
PAYING 70% HIGHER ELECTRICITY
RATES ARE LABOR. UH, LAWS ARE
DIFFERENT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THAN OTHER STATES, AND, UH, WE
HAVE TO COMPETE. SO WE'RE SEEING
A THIS IS A TIME WHERE WE HAVE
WATER SHORTAGES. WE HAVE, UM YOU
KNOW, PAST FOOT SIDE, UH,
REGULATIONS. THERE'S A LOT
HAPPENING IN THE AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY AND CALIFORNIA REALLY
IS, UH, IT'S THE NUMBER ONE
ECONOMY. IT'S A BACKBONE IT IT'S
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES. UH, WHEN
YOU WHEN YOU SEE FARMS LEAVE, UH
OR GET GOBBLED UP BY BIGGER
FARMS, YOU LOSE THOSE FAMILY
FARMS THAT SUPPORT YOUR LITTLE
LEAGUE THAT SUPPORTS YOUR
COMMUNITIES, UH, ALL THROUGHOUT
THE VALLEY AND THROUGH THE
FOOTHILLS, SO I JUST WANNA SAY
AS YOU TRAVEL CALIFORNIA THERE'S
NÓ THERE, YOU SEE THE NUMBER ONE
THING YOU SEE IS AGRICULTURE.
WHETHER YOU'RE IN SAN DIEGO OR
YOU'RE IN MODOC. WE PRODUCE FOOD
FOR THE WORLD AND SO COME OUT
AND CHECK OUT ALL THE GREAT
THINGS THAT ARE GOING TO HAPPEN
NEXT WEEK. UH BUT ALSO REMEMBER
THAT, UH THERE'S GENERATIONS OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE SETTLED IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE HAVING A
TOUGH TIME BECAUSE OF THE QUITE
FRANKLY A LOT OF THE POLICIES
THAT COME OUT OF THIS BODY. SO
WITH THAT, I, UH, SUPPORT S¼ R
70 THREE AND URGENT. I VOTE. AND
YOU, SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF S¼ èC R 70 THREE,
YOU KNOW, JUST YESTERDAY, MOST
OF US WENT TO THE STEAK AND EGG
BREAKFAST PUT ON BY THE
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION TO, UM
LISTEN TO WHAT OUR RANCHING
FAMILIES ARE GOING THROUGH THAT
PRODUCE THE BEEF THAT WE EAT IN
THIS STATE, YOU KNOW, 90 3% OF
THE RANCHES AND FARMS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FAMILY OWNED. AND
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID, WE DO
HAVE LARGE CORPORATIONS COMING
IN TO TAKE OVER SOME OF THAT
LAND. UH MY FAMILY, A RANCHING
FAMILY THAT I MARRIED INTO IS ON
ITS SEVENTH GENERATION. OUR
GRANDCHILDREN WILL BE THE
SEVENTH GENERATION THAT THAT
RUNS THIS FAMILY RUN RANCH AND,
UM, IT'S HARD WORK. IT TAKES A
LOT OF TIME. IT'S NOT A 9 TO 5
JOB, AND, UM A LOT OF TIMES WE
HAVE FAMILY RANCHERS THAT HAVE
BEEN IN BUSINESS FOR A DECADE
AFTER DECADE AFTER DECADE AND,
UM THEN THEY'RE TOLD TO STOP
THEIR COW CALF OPERATION BECAUSE
THERE'S A WILLOW FLY CRUTCHER.
THAT'S GONNA BE, UM, BURROWING
INTO A HILL AND THEY HAVE TO
IMMEDIATELY FIND NEW LAND. FOR
THEIR CATTLE, UM, AGAIN, TRYING
TO KEEP BEEF ON THE SHELVES AT
SUPERMARKETS THAT WE ALL ENJOY,
UH, AS THE SENATOR THAT
REPRESENTS. EXCUSE ME. I'M GONNA
WATCH MY FORMER SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE A HEART
ATTACK RIGHT NOW, AS THE SENATOR
THAT REPRESENTS THE TOP THREE
FOOD PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
WORLD. UM I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT I'M GLAD THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURE IN OUR
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S KNOWN UM,
FOR MORE THAN ITS BEACHES IN OUR
HOLLYWOOD FILM INDUSTRY. UH AND
I'M TELLING YOU THAT OUR AG
INDUSTRY BRINGS IN OVER $50
BILLION WORTH OF REVENUE INTO
THIS STATE. WE SELL THAT EVERY
SINGLE YEAR AS WE LEAD THE
NATION IN DAIRY PRODUCTS IN
GRAPES IN ALMONDS OR ALMONDS,
ACCORDING TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIEBER, UH, AND HUNDREDS OF
COMMODITIES THAT AMERICANS EAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND YOU MAY
NOT HAVE THAT IN YOUR DISTRICT,
BUT I CAN GUARANTEE THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS EAT WHAT WE GROW.
UH, EVEN AS WE FEED AND FUEL THE
NATION. WE HAVE TO REALIZE THAT
FOOD GROWS WHERE WATER FLOWS AND
A LOT OF OUR FARMLAND IS GOING
TO BE FALLOWED. THERE'S AN
ESTIMATE THAT OVER 500,000 ACRES
OF FARMLAND WILL BE LOST BY
AGRICULTURE BY 2050. MORE THAN
300,000 ACRES WILL HAVE BEEN
HIGHLY PRODUCTIVE. UM IRRIGATED
CROPLAND THAT WOULD NOT BE IS
NOT GOING TO BE OUT THERE FOR US
TO BE ABLE TO GROW THE FOOD THAT
YOUR CONSTITUENTS EAT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS EAT COLLEAGUES.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AS
WE HONOR THIS RESOLUTION. TODAY
IN S¼ R 70 TO REALLY PUT, UM,
POLICY TO WHAT THIS RESOLUTION
SAYS AND SUPPORT OUR AG
COMMUNITIES. WE FEED THE WORLD.
UM THIS STATE HAS MORE EGG
PRODUCING COUNTIES. I BELIEVE
SIX. I REPRESENT THE TOP THREE.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE THE TOP SIX
EGG PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE
ENTIRE WORLD. AND IF WE DON'T
NAVIGATE OUR WATER SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO GROW THE FOOD THAT
PEOPLE IN THIS WORLD NEED, UM
THEN WE HAVE A HUGE FOOD
SECURITY ISSUE WHEN INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION THIS YEAR, I'D LIKE
TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO BE MINDFUL
OF THE IMPORTANCE THAT WE NEED
WATER TO GROW THIS FOOD. AND
ALTHOUGH OUR FARMERS HAVE BEEN,
UM VERY, VERY, UH UH, BECOME
CONSERVATIONIST. I CAN SAY THAT
BECAUSE I GREW UP IN A LITTLE
TOWN CALLED ARVIN AND MY MOM WAS
A SINGLE MOM AND I WOULD GO WITH
MY NEIGHBORS THIS YEAR. UH,
SIERRAS AND ELIAS TO GO CHECK
THE WATER AND THE GRAPES WHERE
THEY HAD JUST THESE WELLS. THAT
THESE, UM, IRRIGATION SYSTEM
THEY TURN ON. IT WOULD JUST
FLOOD THE GROUNDWATER, AND NOW
IT'S DROPS, UM, OF WATER THAT
THEY'D USE AND THEY USE WATER
MORE WISELY. THEY TECHNOLOGY TO
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHAT GROUND
NEEDS WATER AND WHAT GROUND
DOESN'T NEED WATER SO THEY ARE
BECOMING CONSERVATIONIST. UM,
WHEN IT COMES TO WATER, AND I
JUST WANT YOU TO WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT POLICY AND INTRODUCING
POLICY, YOU REALLY NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE FOOD THAT WE GROW THE
POLICY THAT THAT FEEDS THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE ARE
REPRESENT, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE FOR THE FOR
THIS BILL, AND TO BE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT THE POLICY THAT WE PUT
FORTH FROM THIS BUILDING THAT
AFFECTS OUR AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? SEE NONE. SENATOR
HURTADO, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE. MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
APPLYING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
TO FILE ITEM? 26. SEE NÓ
OBJECTION. EYES 40 KNOWS ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES NOW, MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM. 29. WE'RE GOING TO LIFT
THE CALL ON THAT MEASURE.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GOD. AYE. ABOUT.
ALRIGHT. I 39 KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WERE
MOVING ON TO SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR? AN
INSANE NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE.
RE ITEMS 37 TO 40. AS SOMEBODY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION. 1 38 1 27
1 30 AS SOMEBODY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 136. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THIS CONSENT CALENDAR. A
AYE. OF ROAD TO G. HØI
ARCHULETA. HØI ASHBY. HØI
ATKINS. HØI BECKER. HØI
BLAKESPEAR. BY BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. I, CORTEZ. AYE,
DALLY. I DIED. HØI EGM. HØI
GLASER. HØI GONZALEZ. I GROWTH.
I REDO. JONES. AYE, LAIRD. AYE,
LIMÓN. HØI MCGUIRE. AYE, MINAR.
AYE, MEN. AYE NEWMAN. I WIN. I,
MILO. IY PATRO B¢O. BUT AYE,
ARGENTINO. IW RUBIO. I SAY ARE
TO HIM. AYE, SKINNER. SMALL
CUEVAS. I STERN HØI UMBERG. HØI
WAHAB. HØI WIENER. I WILL. AYS
38 KNOWS ZERO ON OUR SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW MEMBERS.
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ITEM.
11 NOW IS THE TIME FOR COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR LÀ. THANK
YOU. UM MR PRESIDENT, UH, BUDGET
SUBCOMITTEE. ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL MEET IN THE SWING SPACE IN
ROOM 2100 UPON ADJOURNMENT. IN
ROOM 2100 UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. BUDGET SUB-COMMITTEE
TWO ON ENERGY, NATURAL RESOURCES
AND THE ENVIRONMENT WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM 2215 MINUTES
AFTER ADJOURNMENT. TWO WILL BE
AFTER ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR MANAR
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGETS
UP THREE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. WE'LL MEET 15 MINUTES
AFTER FOUR SESSION IN ROOM 1200.
THANK YOU. THREE WILL BE MEETING
IN ROOM 1215 MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR PADILLA.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUB-COMMITTEE. NUMBER FOUR ON
STATE ADMINISTRATION WILL
CONVENE 15 MINUTES FOLLOWING
ADJOURNMENT ROOM 113 HERE IN THE
CAPITOL. THANK YOU. SUB FOUR
WILL MEET HERE IN THE CAPITAL IN
ROOM 113 15 MINUTES UP TO
ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR WILL HOP
THANK YOU. BUDGET SUB NUMBER
FIVE WILL MEET IN ROOM 112 15
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT. TOP
FIVE WILL MEET IN ROOM 112 HERE
15 MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT.
NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 12 RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW IS
THE TIME FOR A JOURNEY OF
MEMORIES. SENATOR CORTESI.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I RICE UM REQUEST AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY OF JACK
LUCAS, PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AT WEST VALLEY MISSION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT, UM,
LOCATED IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
JACK DIED RECENTLY PEACEFULLY AT
HIS HOME AT THE AGE OF 90 THREE.
SOME OF HIS FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
HERE IN THE GALLERY, AND I WILL
INTRODUCE SOME, UH, AT THE END
OF MY COMMENTS. JACK WAS BORN IN
LINCOLN, NEBRASKA. IN 1930. HE
WAS A DECORATED STUDENT. HE HELD
AN ASSOCIATE OF ARTS FROM FULTON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND A B A AND
MA AND TEACHING CREDENTIAL FROM
SAN JOSE STATE UNIVERSITY. HE
ALSO HAD A DOCTORATE IN
EDUCATION FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
OREGON, AND WE MAY REMAINED AN
AVID FAN OF THE OREGON DUCKS
FOOTBALL TEAM THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE. JACKET DISTINGUISHED
CAREER IN BOTH EDUCATION AND
POLITICS. 42 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
IN HIGH SCHOOL EDUCATION. HE WAS
THE FOUNDER AND PRINCIPAL OF
MARK TWAIN. CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOL FOR 24 OF THOSE YEARS,
GIVING MANY STUDENTS A SECOND
CHANCE AT EDUCATION. IN ADDITION
TO HIS TEACHING, JACK HELD
SEVERAL POSITIONS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. HE SERVED FOUR TERMS
ON THE MONTESINO CITY COUNCIL IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. AND HE WAS
ELECTED MAYOR IN 1986. HE WAS
THEN APPOINTED AS VICE CHAIRMAN
OF THE VALLEY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY OR COUNTYWIDE TRANSIT
AUTHORITY. LATER HE WAS
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE WEST VALLEY
MISSION COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, WHERE HE SERVED AN
ADDITIONAL 20 YEARS. JACK WAS
VERY INVOLVED IN THIS COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF EDUCATION AND
POLITICS. HE COACHED SEVERAL
DIFFERENT SPORTS, INCLUDING
BASEBALL, VARSITY FOOTBALL,
WRESTLING AND VARSITY TENNIS. HE
EVEN COACHED SARATOGA'S FIRST
SANTA CLARA VALLEY ATHLETIC
LEAGUE CHAMPIONSHIP. HE WAS A
LIFELONG VOLUNTEER, NOT
SURPRISINGLY, COMMITTING HIS
TIME TO MANY DIFFERENT CAUSES.
HE SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AMERICAN RED CROSS
IN LOS GATTIS COMMUNITY CONCERT
ASSOCIATION. HE SPENT 20 THREE
YEARS WITH VASQUEZ LIONS CLUB.
JACK MET HIS WIFE, FRANCES,
WHILE THEY WERE STUDENTS AT SAN
JOSE STATE. THEY SHARED A LOVE
OF TEACHING. SHE ALSO EARNED A
TEACHING CREDENTIAL AND BECAME
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER AND
LIBRARIAN. I ENJOYED SEEING JACK
AT RIBBON CUTTINGS AT WEST
VALLEY COLLEGE. UM, ESPECIALLY
OVER RECENT YEARS, WHERE HE WAS
INVOLVED IN PUSHING FORWARD SO
MANY KEY PROJECTS AMAZING
PROJECTS. AND AT THE COLLEGE OF
ADAPTIVE ARTS ON THE CAMPUS, A
UNIQUE ONE OF A KIND SCHOOL FOR
DISABLED STUDENTS. HE WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN RECENT DECISIONS
TO OFFER FREE TUITION AND
SUPPORT TO WEST VALLEY MISSION
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ALSO
CUTTING EDGE WORK. IT'S HARD. I
KNOW FOR ALL OF US IN LIFE. AND
I THINK, SOMETIMES PARTICULARLY
IN POLITICS TO STAND SIDE BY
SIDE. WAS SUCH WONDERFUL PERSONS
IN THIS CASE, SUCH A WONDERFUL
PERSON IN JACK LUCAS. THERE ONE
DAY. GONE THE NEXT HE WAS
HEALTHY, RIGHT UP TO THE LAST
TIME I SAW HIM SO RECENTLY.
JACK'S LEGACY LIVES ON THROUGH
HIS CHILDREN, KATHY JANET JOHN
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN, JIM,
KATIE, ANTHONY, SAMANTHA AND
LUKE JACK WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR
HIS IMPACT ON THE EDUCATION OF
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS. HIS LEGACY
WILL CONTINUE. AND HE'LL BE
REMEMBERED, OF COURSE FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITIES.
THE CITIES OF SARATOGA, LOS GAS
AND MONTESINO. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY'S
SESSION IN MEMORY OF JACK LUCAS.
AND IF I MAY, MR PRESIDENT, I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE FAMILY
MEMBERS IN THE GALLERY WHO HAVE
JOINED US HERE TODAY AND THANK
THEM FOR LETTING US SHARE IN HIS
LIFE. UH, FOR SHARING HIM WITH
THE PUBLIC AND FOR SHARING YOUR
TIME WITH US TODAY, UH, IN THE
SENATE GALLERY. WE WELCOME AS
OUR GUESTS THAT JACK'S DAUGHTER
AND JANET DONAHUE, SON IN LAW,
BOB FRY. THEY'RE HERE VISITING
FROM PETALUMA. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE, PARTICULARLY AND
ROBERT AND VICKY SCHULER INTO
THOSE WITH THE IRISH HERITAGE.
WISH YOU WERE HERE UNDER BETTER
CIRCUMSTANCES, BUT PERHAPS
FITTING THAT YOU'RE HERE WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU AND WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. KNOCKS
UP IS SENATOR WEINER. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES UH,
IT'S WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RISE TO ASK THE SENATE ADJOURN A
MEMORY OF MOO LEÓN, UH, MAORI,
THE FORMER, UH, CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE TENDERLOIN
NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
MAJOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING, UH,
NONPROFIT BUILDERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO. UH, HE WAS ALSO A
FORMER STAFF MEMBER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AND HE PASSED AWAY
SUDDENLY ON FEBRUARY. 23RD BORN
INTO A AN IMMIGRANT, UH
FARMWORKER FAMILY? UH MAURILIO,
UH, BECAME THE FIRST IN HIS
FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE,
GRADUATING WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE FROM U, èC BERKELEY AND
A MASTERS FROM, UH, HARVARD
KENNEDY SCHOOL. AS THE èC E Ó
OF Tð  N, Dð èC, UH, HE LED
EFFORTS TO REIMAGINE COMMUNITY
PRESERVATION, NEIGHBORHOOD
DEVELOPMENT AND TO CREATE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES, LEANING
ON HIS EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN
THE PRIVATE, PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT SECTORS. UH MAORI,
DEDICATED HIS PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL LIFE TO FOSTERING
OPPORTUNITY, EQUITY AND
GENERATIONAL CHANGE FOR
IMMIGRANTS FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND FAMILIES OF COLOR.
HIS FIERCE PASSION FOR HOUSING
JUSTICE IS EXEMPLIFIED THROUGH
THE RESIDENT. HE STABLY HOUSED
THE BUILDINGS HE CREATED, UH,
THROUGH WHICH HIS LEGACY WAS
FORMED. UH, HE'LL BE WARMLY
REMEMBERED BY ALL THE LIVES HE
TOUCHED AS A FAMILY MEMBER,
FRIEND AND LEADER AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT THIS WAS A HUGE AND
VERY, VERY SHOCKING AND
SURPRISING BLOW, UH, TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY IN
SAN FRANCISCO. UH PEOPLE ARE ARE
JUST DEVASTATED. UM UH, HE HAS
SURVIVED BY MANY RELATIVES,
INCLUDING HIS PARENTS, UH,
NICHOLAS AND MARIE AND MARIA,
HIS FIANCE AND PARTNER RE ALINA
UM LACHLAN. HIS BROTHERS. UM
SOLOMON LEÓN, UH DARIO LEÓN AND
HIS SISTER MARIA DE LOS ANGELES.
LEÓN UH, PLEASE JOIN ME IN
ADJOURNING. UH THE SENATE IN
MEMORY OF MAURILIO LEÓN. THANK
YOU. OUR DEEPEST GALVIN. SENATE
CONDOLENCES. PLEASE BRING THE
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. OH,
SENATOR LIMONA ON THIS ON THIS
ADJOURNMENT, SO MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY. ALSO TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MAIDU. I WENT TO
SCHOOL WITH MAURILIO AND WITH
HIS BROTHER SAL, UM AND I HAVE
KNOWN HIM THROUGHOUT THE YEARS.
I KNOW WHAT MARIO WAS LIKE, UM,
AS A SCHOLAR, UM, HE WAS
DEDICATED. HE WAS FOCUSED. HE
WAS PART OF, UM, A LATINO
FRATER. THE GAMMA ZETA ALPHA AND
AT BERKELEY AND, UH, HE WAS
SOMEONE WHO WAS VERY DEDICATED
TO HIS WORK TO HIS PASSION TO
BERKELEY, UM TO THE CHICANO
LATINO ALUMNI ASSOCIATION AT
BERKELEY, AND HIS LOSS IS, UM,
VERY SUDDEN. TO ALL OF US WHO
WORKED WITH HIM. UM AND WHO KNOW
HIM? UM, HE WAS SOMEONE. UM, WHO
, UH, WOULD TEXT ME AND WOULD
CHECK IN WITH ME AND WOULD RUN
INTO ME WITH ME RUN. WITH RUN
INTO ME. UM WE WOULD RUN INTO
EACH OTHER. UH SORRY. UH UH AND,
UH, YOU KNOW, WOULD ALWAYS JUST
BE SO AWARE OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN THE COMMUNITY. HIS
FOCUS WAS AFFORDABLE, UM,
HOUSING, BUT HE CARED SO BROADLY
ABOUT SO MANY ISSUES IMPACTING
CALIFORNIANS. UM HE CARED ABOUT
EDUCATION HE CARED ABOUT, UH,
YOU KNOW, UH, THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
HE BROUGHT INFORMATION,
EDUCATION AND LIGHT TO MANY
POLICY ISSUES, UM, BECAUSE HE
UNDERSTOOD THE INTERSECTION WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE, UM, TO THOSE OF
US WHO WHO KNOW HIM? WHO KNEW
HIM? UM THE LOSS IS SUDDEN. IT
WAS A SHOCK. UM AND I KNOW TODAY
IN OAKLAND, YOU KNOW, MANY
PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM WILL BE
GATHERING. UM TO, UH, YOU KNOW,
SAY GOODBYE TO HIM, SO I JUST
WANNA PERSONALIZE. UM, THIS IN A
DEEP WAY, BECAUSE THIS IS
SOMEONE WHO I WENT TO SCHOOL
WITH WHO I KNEW. WELL WHO, UM,
WE WERE IN CLASSES TOGETHER AND
WHO I'VE KEPT IN TOUCH WITH. UM
AND THAT IS A LOSS TO MANY OF
US, UM IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN, OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND WE ASKED THAT
THE NAME BE BROUGHT FORWARD.
SENATOR JONES. MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS. UH THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF THE THIS MORNING IS
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
ANNOUNCE THE PASSING OF ONE OF
OUR PREDECESSORS HERE IN THE
STATE SENATE. SENATOR RICHARD
DICK JAY MONTEITH OF MODESTO WAS
92 WHEN HE PEACEFULLY PASSED
AWAY RECENTLY SURROUNDED BY LOVE
AND FAMILY. TAKE MY TEETH WAS A
PROUD CENTRAL VALLEY NATIVE
RESIDENT AND LEADER. AT A YOUNG
AGE. HE WAS A STAR ATHLETE IN
THE VALLEY AND LATER AT STANFORD
, WHERE HE EARNED A BACHELOR'S
OF ARTS IN SOCIOLOGY. HE WENT ON
TO A LONG AND HAPPY CAREER AT
AGRIBUSINESS AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
56, HE WOULD ENTER THE WORLD OF
POLITICS, WINNING A HOTLY
CONTESTED STATE SENATE SEAT IN
1994 AND GETTING RE-ELECTED IN
1998. AFTER LEAVING THE STATE
SENATE DUE TO TERM LIMITS.
SENATOR MONTEITH WAS ELECTED
THREE TIMES TO THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RETIRED FROM THERE IN 2018. MANY
POLITICIANS TALK ABOUT WALKING
PRECINCTS. WELL DICK MONTEITH
NOT ONLY TALK THE TALK, HE
WALKED THE WALK AND MANY OF THE
STANISLAUS PRECINCTS OVER THE
YEARS A GREGARIOUS MAN WITH AN
INFECTIOUS LAUGH. DICK MONTEITH
LOVED LISTENING TO AND HELPING
PEOPLE. HE WAS A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVANT. MONTEITH IS SURVIVED BY
THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE. HIS WIFE,
JEANNIE, AND MANY CHILDREN,
STEPCHILDREN AND GRANDKIDS. MANY
OF YOU MAY KNOW HIS DAUGHTER IN
LAW. HEIDI ELLISON, WHO WORKED
AS A SENATE STAFFER IN THE OLD
CAPITOL FOR MANY YEARS, AND OF
COURSE, MANY OF YOU KNOW HER
HUSBAND, PETER KELLISON, WHO IS
STILL A LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE.
SENATOR SENATOR DICK MONTEITH
WILL BE REMEMBERED AS A MAN WHO
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO THE LORD,
HIS FAMILY, HIS COMMUNITY AND,
OF COURSE, HIS STANFORD
CARDINAL. I ASK THAT THE SENATE
TODAY ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
SENATOR DICK MONTEITH. AND
QUEUES SENATOR ALVARADO GILL ON
THIS ADJOURNMENT. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. UM I JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTEE IN
REQUESTING THE SENATE ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF FORMER SENATOR
DICK MONTY AND STANISLAUS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR 12 YEARS.
STANISLAUS COUNTY HAS A PROUD
HISTORY OF ELECTING LEGISLATORS
WHO STAND UP FOR THEM,
REGARDLESS OF PARTY. AND DICK
WAS ONE OF THOSE MEMBERS AND A
TRUE FRIEND OF AGRICULTURE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. DICK WAS
ALWAYS ACTIVE IN THE COMMUNITY,
EVEN BETWEEN HIS STINTS IN
ELECTED OFFICE. IN ADDITION TO
ALL THE ACTIVITIES AND
INVESTMENTS ALREADY LISTED BY
THE SENATOR FROM SANTEE, DICK
ALSO SERVED IN THE U S¼ NAVAL
RESERVE WITH THE TREASURE, UH,
WAS THE TREASURER OF THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA EGG HANDLERS
AND A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
TURLOCK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. HE
WAS STRONG INSTITUTIONALIST WHO
REVERED THE SENATE AND A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR HIS COMMUNITY WHILE
SERVING IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT. OUR
THOUGHTS ARE WITH SENATOR
MONTE'S FAMILY AND LOVED ONES
AND THE COMMUNITY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY VALLEY THAT LOVED AND
CARED FOR HIM AS WELL. I URGE
YOU, UH, NÓ. I VOTE. SORRY.
THANK YOU. OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE PASSING OF
THE SENATOR. WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. IF
THERE'S NÓ OTHER BUSINESS,
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE JUSTICE
CLEAR? THANK YOU SO MUCH, UH, MR
PRESIDENT. I HOPE EVERYONE HAS A
WONDERFUL ST PATTY'S DAY. LONG
LIVE NICK HARDIMAN. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY. MARCH 18TH 2024 AT 12:30
P.M. MEMBERS OF THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL 330, AT WHICH
TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE RECONVENE ON MONDAY
AT 1230.